[Music]
[Applause]
i think of chris sims occasionally
sometimes it's football related and i
was wondering as soon as baker mayfield
went to carolina how that would change
his rankings of his quarterbacks always
have great respect for chris and how he
ranks his quarterbacks he's not afraid
of criticism here pro football talk live
co-host former nfl quarterback himself
kind enough to join us uh where did you
have baker mayfield in cleveland and
does that ranking change with him in
carolina
no it doesn't it doesn't change in my
opinion uh you know again i tried to do
it dan you know i try to leave the team
and the support system out of this
exercise when you talk about ranking the
quarterbacks because yeah again you know
it's hey one quarterback's got the
advantage of having josh mcdaniels or
kyle shanahan or mcveigh not everybody
has that so i try to not be biased as
far as that is concerned and ranking the
quarterbacks baker mayfield i had him at
17 right a guy that i do think has the
talent to be in the top 10-ish
conversation for sure i'm not sure top
five ever but top tennis yes and dan i
mean uh panthers are one of those teams
that i said this last year and i'm going
to say it again
i like what they got on paper there's a
lot of things to like about their
football team you know they fixed their
offensive line which was the weak part
of their team last year that should be
better we know the defense was great if
mccaffrey can stay healthy there's good
receivers i do think the offense will be
better and i think that baker mayfield
will be the starting quarterback there
in carolina when all said and done okay
more important for the success of
carolina this year christian mccaffrey
or baker mayfield
oh i'm gonna i'm still gonna go with i'm
still going to go with baker mayfield i
am you know again
hey you want christian mccaffrey to me
that's like icing on the cake he
certainly can make them you know go from
an offense that's real good to great uh
i know that but at the same time uh
it's
i don't know it's easier to fill the
void of a running back out now i know
it's even as talented as a christian
mccaffrey is you know they can come up
with other ways to feed the ball to dj
moore robbie anderson you know one of
terrace marshall their new receiver that
they got last year in the draft so
that's a tough one but the way the
league's set up and i think for that
team right there no they need a
quarterback not only that's talented
take care of the ball make some plays
but the other thing this is where i say
baker mayfield's going to win this dan
is
he brings an edge to your football team
you can see i know not everybody loves
baker mayfield but
there is a leadership factor i think
with baker mayfield that players can
latch onto and like and it can add a
little fire to your football team that i
haven't seen from sam darnold yet that's
for sure sam darnold's 25
i know
it feels like he's been in the nfl for
eight years
right is it is he going to fall in line
with the jameis winston uh
mitchell trubisky or or is he going to
be a journeyman
i
i'm not giving up on sam darnold i still
think it feels like carolina is well
yeah you know that to me is
the way he played last year it wasn't
good we know that and again i don't want
to blame him totally you heard me say a
number of times you know with that
offense there it was very predictable so
it didn't make it easy to play
quarterback that's for sure uh but you
know i do think baker mayfield has a
bigger arm knows how to play the
position a little bit better and man sam
darnold's just been in some tough
situations so i do think he could be one
of these guys that's kind of like a
career journey men and then maybe three
or four years down the road we start to
go oh man look at this guy he got a
place that's good and he's starting to
show us he can play but man he's had a
lot of things that certainly haven't
helped him you know throughout his
career hasn't had a great support system
anywhere i wonder who's the next ryan
fitzpatrick
uh i got you there yeah i hear you um
that guy i mean
sam darnold has more talent than a ryan
fitzpatrick that's for sure but i hear
what you're saying i'm trying to look at
my list here to see if there's anybody
else out there you know i do think
there's
you know maybe some guys down the list
uh you know gino smith has a chance to
be that maybe even a drew lock that kind
of guy and then we'll see how some of
these second and third year quarterbacks
play this year maybe they end up being
you know some of those you know ryan
fitzpatrick too what about jared goff
ooh that could be another one i mean yes
golf is to me one of the biggest
question marks going into the season
this year i think detroit's gonna be a
better football team i'd be shocked if
they're not you know they're they're
gonna i thought they might make a move
at quarterback this year and do
something but this is where to me the
politics of the nfl come in they want to
hey we we gave away matthew stafford he
won the super bowl so we got to show the
guy we got back is pretty good too we
didn't just trade him for nothing and i
think that's why they stick with them
and but he is chris you know belichick
do you think that belichick held on to
nikhil harry longer than he should have
because
it would be even more embarrassing if he
cut a guy that they drafted in the first
round i do think that those guys get
nine lives for sure you know they get
the the cushion of you know maybe the
fourth rounder who made seven mistakes
he gets cut but the first rounder you
can make 20 mistakes and they still say
hey you're getting better let's try to
keep working it out and i do think they
held on to him a little too long but you
know i think he had a little chemistry
with cam newton and that's where
that like oh wait we gotta like that cam
can throw back shoulder balls and do all
that and jump balls and we like that but
there was nothing else and that was the
issue in the kill harry coming out of
college to me he was good with the ball
in his hand but he could not separate
running routes and i think he's been on
the the trade market for a while and
finally you know they just cut the cord
and moved on help me understand the
perception of lamar jackson they just
had a top 10 list with the executives
and coaches and players and he's not a
top 10 quarterback feels like he's
cooled off considerably here and if
you're a receiver do you want to go to
baltimore to play with him
yeah i think they're all legitimate
questions he you know i made him number
10
but you know again that's off of a year
that was not stellar last year he did
not play good football so i think that's
where you see some of these question
marks a little bit from some of these
gm's it's just you know he was over
aggressive he didn't take care of the
football you know left a lot of yards
and completions on the field when you go
back and watch just because how i'm
going to force the ball down to mark
andrews you know 40 yards down the
middle wait hollywood brown's open for
eight yards right here let's just throw
it to him and move the chains i think
those were the issues last year and then
i think dude i do think people in the
nfl think he lost maybe a half a gear or
a gear in his running and they're scary
you know i tried to say this before
quarterbacks like lamar jackson there's
still yes say
a stigma around them around the nfl
there's a lot of people that will go i'm
never going to do that or go down that
road as a quarterback because i don't
think you can win a super bowl that way
and i think that's a legitimate question
i question that could you see them
franchise tagging him
yes i do because i think they're in too
deep at this point like
they've built this is where he has
tremendous leverage they've built the
team around him and his skill set and
they've made it about a plethora of
running backs in our o-line and we're
gonna overpower you there and of course
greg not roman the offensive coordinator
he's a run game genius he is very good
pass game is good i wish there was a
little bit more at times but in running
game i mean he's special so that's where
he has a great advantage i think you
know as far as contract negotiations
talking to chris sims pro football talk
live co-host former nfl quarterback i'm
wondering if jimmy garoppolo's future
immediate future is attached to what
happens with desean watson if watson
let's say he gets a year
would the browns
be comfortable given that roster and say
we'll stay with jacoby bersette
or do you think that there would be a
market for jimmy garoppolo to be the
starting quarterback at least for one
year in cleveland
i would question it i mean if i'm
cleveland i would think about it for
sure if i'm the houston texans i'm
thinking about it now to me i think you
know and again with garoppolo i had him
the number 19 quarterback i've had them
number 20 i've had them all around that
range and i think that's another guy
if you talk to people in the nfl i think
a lot of them go wait is jimmy i mean we
know he's good and you can win games but
how good is he is he a product of
mcdaniels and shanahan who just you know
serve up plays and things on a silver
platter you know quite often to make it
very easy on a quarterback i think
that's the the big question about him
but if i'm cleveland with that roster
i mean again i think it's a borderline
super bowl-ish type roster
i i would think about yes bringing in
jimmy garoppolo over the year i don't
you know again i don't think you're
going to cause any problems into the
future with the deshaun watson issue or
anything there uh i would certainly
consider it strongly yeah
and the demo samuel contract situation
yeah seems quiet
and i don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing
i think it's a good thing i think debo
i mean again outside looking in uh the
thing i've said from the start where i
just i always thought this would be
resolved is one
he's the best player on their football
team he's the number one weapon on their
team and shanahan with all his you know
runs and reverses and sweeps and play
action passes who's better at doing that
than debo samuel so from that standpoint
i went man san francisco ain't gonna let
him go and then the other thing i said
from the start with florio a lot was
shanahan has the utmost confidence and
his ability to communicate with players
you know he he sean mcvay some of these
young coaches you know they can tote or
what do i want to say toe the the fine
line a little bit of hey we're friends
but i'm your coach and i might cuss you
out a little bit here and there and tell
you to be better at this and i just
always thought shanahan would kind of
work his way through to debo and
i don't think it'll i think it's a
matter of time before we hear something
done long term
you went to texas
yeah a big deal when you declared
yeah arch manning has declared
yeah
how big a deal
is it going to be for him with all
that's involved there and
you know the whole family's involved
you're eventually going to be moving
into the sec so it
what's arch manning walking into at
texas
he's he's walking into the you know
walking under the microscope is what
you're going to walk into you know the
sec we know it's king of college
football
i'm not sure there's a city in the sec
though
that is quite as big as austin is has
the media coverage
and then
you know covers their local team like
it's a pro football squad that that
that's to me is going to be one of the
great advantages for arch manning if he
can get through all that is he'll be
ready for the nfl as far as media
scrutiny and being under the microscope
and all that but man he's going to be
there but i mean that's that's that fan
base the longhorns our fan base they're
thirsty right now i mean come on i'm
thirsty what the hell is going on i'm
sick of it you know i mean i really am
and i just think
you know like me and i'm not trying to
pat myself on the back or anything but
the thing i'm excited for is one yeah we
got a good quarterback in archbanning
that's awesome but i know the ripple
effects
and the ripple effects to me are we're
going to change the the whole the whole
organization or the university because
now just like when i was there all of a
sudden
oh wait the top two receivers in the
country want to go oh hey roy williams
you want to come here and play with me
hey come on and visit let's go oh we got
roy williams oh cedric benson you want
to come here because we got a good
quarterback at a good receiver boom
cedric come on a visit let's go best
tackles in football all of a sudden we
built a team in two or three years where
we go we're one of the best teams in
college football and i think arch
manning can be that jump off spot for
texas once again
i said it at the time that he signed
with texas
um if his name was arch smith
would would it be
would this be as big a deal like just
having the lineage there
uh
it feels like you know we hear the name
and we go wait can't miss
how much yeah i know
like he can miss we've seen can't miss
players
miss
definitely definitely there's a lot that
goes into it it's just like your last
name like you're you're chris sims and
your dad won a super bowl and
okay
you're gonna be the savior
yeah right
even when i got to the nfl people just
thought hey dad gave him a magic pill
and he might win a super bowl too well
yeah it didn't work out i'm one of those
failures you're talking about or
sometimes it doesn't happen that way i
mean yes uh
that's you know i would think he's used
to those expectations by this point in
his life i mean again that just kind of
comes with the territory of manning and
all that and again he's got you know
some people around him as far as peyton
eli you know his father his grandfather
who were going to be able to you know
keep his head on straight and i think he
knows what's important uh but yeah
there's going to be big expectations he
certainly is and i was shocked to see
when he committed there i did not think
he was going to leave the
normal sec comfort zone but i'm happy as
hell it's happened and hopefully it can
uh catapult us back into the natural
scene and you didn't fail because you
got to the nfl you just yeah you know
people expect you know to be great and
continue to be great but also steve
sarkeesian
yeah is he better as a coordinator than
he is as a coach
and and
and the fact that he has been
he's been there with a lot of very good
quarterbacks in his career i don't know
what role that plays if he if arch
manning doesn't go you know to play for
georgia or play for alabama
that you're going to go to a guy who
might get you more ready for the nfl in
sarkeesian is that is that a fair
assessment here i think to me it's i
think maybe the number one thing of why
he went there uh again yeah you know the
way the quarterback situation there is
at texas right now there's nobody set in
stone where you gotta go oh man i don't
know if he can beat him out is he better
than quinn ewers though i mean this was
he was the number one he was the number
one quarterback in america uh yeah you
know i know and i mean listen and some
of that instagram highlights i saw at
quinn viewers i went oh my gosh whoa can
he throw the football but you know i
don't know i don't know where the status
of that is he did leave ohio state i've
heard a few things here and there
uh i would think again
this is the manning family they're very
smart and calculated
and i would think steve sarkesian would
love to have
a manning be that jump off spot for his
head coaching career and the school
itself
i would think that arch manning is going
to be
you know the leader in the clubhouse as
far as he's gonna get a lot more chances
to be that guy because of some of the
circumstances and that's fine listen i'm
not that's just the way the world works
a little bit and we'll see if he can
take advantage of that when he does get
those chances great to talk to you chris
have a good weekend thank you
anytime dp you the man see you guys see
you later chris sims pro football talk